who's buying short films today well now
that's obviously the ever-changing sort
of question right now right I mean with
with the new streaming platforms of apps
the development and discussion about
short content short films where the
place of short films is in this could
have sort of new world of streaming is
like sort of the great unknown it's
something we're excited about because we
think there's great potential for shorts
to be its own big market and I think
it's something that we're trying to get
behind and really excited about outside
of obviously the big question or sort of
the broad answer there are specific
companies that are looking for content
short content we work with a few of them
and one of them is dust they look for
sci-fi films so there are specific
content they're looking for is sci-fi so
we're sci-fi adventure you know the kind
of realm of science fiction be a tech
VFX and things like that but they're
looking for those films so we like to
talk with them and work with them all
the time we love a great film hey we
have a great sci-fi film here take a
look you know they like it they could
acquire known exclusive you know so
their deals are fair and you get more
exposure so it's kind of win-win for
everyone
and they also have a company I don't
know if it's sister company or just
their other streaming companies alter
and altered its horror films so their
focus is more horror thriller and so
they're both obviously genre based but
really cool areas of distribution
opportunities for for filmmakers looking
for that and getting exposure and
actually getting acquired now again in
all exclusive way so they're not taking
your film and taking the IP or really
anything like that so you know it's
definitely an opportunity for filmmakers
to get more exposure and I have another
place to to get distribution and of
course everyone knows shorts TV shorts
TVs been doing it a long time so they're
always acquiring shorts and they're
linear on DirecTV and AT&T and all that
stuff universe so they're on television
and so that's their area angle and
they're always looking for shorts all
the time so they've but they've been
doing it for a while but they're not in
the streaming aspect the streaming
aspect you've seen companies like the
dust and stuff and then you have
crunchyroll does anime so there's all
these different sort of at the moment
apps that are focused apps are web sites
focused on indirect direct markets right
so anime crunchyroll sci-fi dust you
know things like that um you know
there's a kripp TV app they do horror as
well so there's always different apps
and websites that are focused on certain
genres or styles of film that are
looking to acquire shorts all different
deals and different things as far as
civility or non exclusivity but now that
that's a that's a big deal like this is
something that's this ever-changing
growing this wasn't this this wasn't the
way 5 10 15 years ago this is you know
when we started there was nothing there
was there lino Schwartz distribution
there was no none of it so there was no
opportunity for Schwartz they didn't
have any place in a distribution
landscape and now there's there's I'm
just naming a few there sense so many
more that are doing this it's it's
pretty well to think of what can come
you know their stuff focus on certain
genres and there's there's also apps are
looking for just general short content
and and ever-changing we have our own
platform we're looking to build up and
work on and it's called bit pics so bit
pics TV is our website in our app we're
on Amazon and Roku looking to grow that
right now it's just a general Schwartz
sort of landscape we have shorts from
all type of genres and everything that
we have sort of best of fest and things
from the monthly screenings and films we
like we have on the on the platform in
subscription-based and so that's
something that we're looking to grow and
take the next level it's something
that's not at that place yet where it's
huge and well-known and you know
universally know you know worldwide and
things like that or you know but that's
something we feel they can get there and
shorts of a huge market because
worldwide people like watching shorts
India China Europe Europe they love
shorts so now if you have a place where
everyone can focus on one area to go to
you know you think of hey I want to
stream certain TV shows whatever you
think Netflix now what about shorts if
we have the place that everyone says hey
want to go to bit pay for shorts that
would that be amazing they can find all
the best shorts in the world they can
find them there you know that's
something that we're exploring you know
and and it's something I think the
audience is now there more than ever cuz
again TVs are not
TVs anymore it's your phone you can
literally sit in your phone and watch
stuff anywhere you are and it's
something that young generations are not
doing so we're all trying to figure how
to capitalize on this and make this be
the next thing so maybe short film
makers or short content creators can
make more money can have their shorts
made and you get a bigger audience than
just really cool festivals are some some
eyeballs and some streaming sites and
stuff but be recognized worldwide you
know in a different way and I really do
think that this is where things are
going I think in the next five to 10
years it's gonna be a big change in
shift for what the perception of shorts
is we talked about earlier what a short
films me what is what it what are shorts
and then 15 years ago yeah it was just
hey you made a cool thesis film or art
film
she try to show the festival now that's
what it was and you know it's just
strictly a calling card that film could
make you any money that film couldn't be
its own thing
not on that now there's so many places
and avenues of ways a short can go
whether it's attribution whether it's it
is a calling car whether it's a short to
be a feature whether it's TV series
whether it's you just make great shorts
and that's all you do is make awesome
shorts and that's what you do you don't
have to necessarily just be hey I made a
short to go to be oh make a feature film
or to showcase myself no you can make
great shorts and tell short stories in a
way that can be your calling card in
that way not like just to go on do
something else so this whole world with
all these different apps and platforms
that are looking for films I mean I
wouldn't make some money than we didn't
get more exposure it's just it's huge I
mean it's it's definitely something that
I mean this is changed the whole
landscape of what we're doing and that's
why we even see more submissions not
only the growth of festival but the fact
that more people are making short films
than ever before in the world that's
just this is a fact so it's really
exciting I mean you have those platforms
there's Femi oh does their staff pick so
you have the most I pick for exposure
and they do that there's a short of the
week and that website and that you know
they do that so the short of the week is
a place where they pick out their short
expose them and give you a sort of stamp
of approval for your film they do that
and that's really cool so you have these
different sites and whether it's sites
whether it's apps that they're looking
for content so now not only just m-80s
doing contests all time looking for
content you know they've done promotions
with us and so 18t is looking for stuff
for their channels all the time but TV
they're looking for shorts and they're
doing contests for short filmmakers to
give them prizes like it's just sort of
this new Wild West new world like
there's actually opportunities to not
just showcase yourself we'll make money
and also get Garner's more exposure than
ever before which is really cool I mean
it to be part of that there's something
we couldn't have foreseen back then but
now as we position ourselves as a strong
festival and things in the short space
we want to see how we can push this
thing further and grow you know the
online and capability and app capability
you know the festival all of it to grow
it to new heights and and to just make
short films the new sort of new premiere
content you know I think there's a
there's a chance and I think that's
pretty cool and I think that's something
that definitely you know next five to
ten years we're going to see keep
changing
you